[Music]
the boys are back
welcome to thick boys studios what's up
dickies stickers thick of tears
thick gums
little freaking uh warthogs
truffle pigs
sometimes i feel like a truffle pig
what a sick job little truffle piggy
little truffle pig i'm a little sneaker
pig sniff out sneakers they sniff out
truffles i sniff out sneakers what's
going on kids fresh off the plane from
sacramento california the capital of
this lovely state we call california
and it looks like the math mandates
ended friday at midnight
so all i'm hoping for is they get rid of
the mask in kids schools which new york
did usually follow whatever new york
does so hopefully we're next so my kid
doesn't grow up think that everybody's a
ninja
hopefully they get that done but uh
shout out to sacramento man uh dude
the economy as far as
stand-up goes is in full effect
you know i've been torn all during the
pandemic it's always weird because you
know a lot of places have
freaking um
you know mandates or vaccine stuff and
you know so a lot of people don't want
to come out so it's it gets weird man
but now that stuff's going away things
are back and popping
back and popping
that's my boy craig
uh we
i mean i kept saying he looks like the
guy from jay and silent bob
and then we had uh
there was this dope ass uh
photographer there and i was like dude
we gotta do a picture and then i was
like let me see what jane saw and bob
does and then we just re
created that
and jay from jane silent bob but almost
better than dawson's creek in the pie
[ __ ] good luck good luck boys
what's interesting is
what's up that's the actual dude yeah
yeah that's cool dude commented on it
and then so did uh homeboy liked it
what's this j silent bob liked it kevin
smith
what's interesting about kevin smith's
kevin smith was on farm kid years ago i
remember and the story about kevin smith
is i don't i'll say i know who kevin
smith is he's one of the most brilliant
minds in my generation he's so talented
and so uh they someone booked him come
on the show i think he was promoting
something this is years ago dude we're
in playa vista remember yeah and he
comes in in his standard hockey jersey
and this is before he's like vegan and
doing all that stuff and he comes in
again we don't know him brian doesn't
know him i don't know him chin doesn't
know him and he comes in and he thought
it was audio only but you know what the
we were trying to push the video back in
the day
and um
he
was not happy because he realized his
video and he was self-conscious by which
i get i feel you on that brother
but um
again we didn't know each other so right
away we did not i i would say we didn't
get along we butted heads it was just
like a very bad first impression
at first yeah and then in my head i was
like all right dude then don't do it
yeah because he was like i'm not doing
video but so you gotta take that down
like
hold on this isn't the kevin smith show
dude he's great and i'm not doing like
all right cool dude well appreciate you
coming down
and then he walked out and you know i
walked out and then he was like all
right i'll do it but let's do this i'm
like i'm up for that and then um we did
the show and it's literally top five
guests you said how much you're about
me and him just brode out after that
like i absolutely love him he's such a
talented dude and to be fair like his
publicist or whoever booked the show
probably should have told him it's video
you know like come on dude what are you
doing so maybe he's caught off guard you
know i'm sure you know he does big boy
interviews and he's actually doing us a
favor you know so but i mean dude we've
interviewed everybody and he is top five
hands down dude he's so talented so fun
so funny
just a talented dude man
been on rogan a few times too
yeah there he is
he want to sit and call him seat but
yeah now he's lost a bunch of weight man
he's lost a bunch of weight
yeah yeah there he's just a bunch of
weight there he is wow
the kid himself running into that would
be the fighter and how to pose on set of
the goldbergs
that's funny man yeah because kevin
smith was a director
of one of the goldbergs episodes wow so
talented man yeah i absolutely love them
love them one of my faves but yeah so uh
craig came out for that and he looks
just like the guys from jaden's silent
bob and shout out to sacramento one of
my favorite clubs punchline and uh we
got a week off because i'm in town
because we had a fight companion
this mother truck and saturday for the
big ufc 272 uh mazwell doll versus colby
covington and uh the guest for that um
the guest for that fight companion is um
this is gonna be a fight heavy show i'm
not gonna lie to you guys we're gonna
get down to the nitty-gritty the x and
the nose because we got a straight hall
of famer we got mma royalty josh barnett
in studio joining the fight companion
driving all the way from hollywood to
calabasas and then we also got
a fan favorite matt matrion flying back
in so you got matt matrione and josh
barnett uh doing the fight campaign for
ufc 272
uh only on thick boy come watch the uh
fights with us man
and to be honest i would as much as i
like doing the pay-per-view ones i see
the big fights and i have to plan my
touring around the big fights i want to
get some fight nights in too man because
i think it's better for the fans when
it's not a
you know pricey pay-per-view when it's a
fight especially it's a good fight night
we could definitely do some stuff with
that fight tonight um the flashback uh
fight night with matt matron is
available right now it just went up last
week we covered the fight between
the two of us which was a tad awkward
um his derrick lewis fight and then also
the fedor fight and when you watch it
you will see um
what i think makes mitrione an outlier
in this crazy fight world where
you know he's fighting fedor and he
doesn't hold him in the same regards as
the rest of us you know like when i
fought croak up i knew i was fighting a
straight up legend a straight up you
know a guy who's going to go down in
history for what he's achieved and that
you know there's pressure there man
there's a lot of pressure and sometimes
you have too much respect and that
happens more often than not where a
young lion's fighting a a legend you
have so much respect you don't fight
like yourself
and then you know that probably happened
with me a little bit in the first second
round with grow cop
and obviously it happened with him and
pat perry and you know pat bay pressure
won that fight ended up getting choked
out by you know uh his hero and merkel
crow cop
but matt does not
have that same respect it's not that
he's disrespectful he just doesn't care
he didn't uh come into the fight game of
fight fanny came in to let make money
and that's all this thing was for him is
something to do
you know football was over and he had
this crazy athletic ability and
poured that into fighting and you know
really focus on stand up and next thing
you know he's freaking fighting fedor in
mass square garden and what's great
about that that was the first fight that
i also uh was the analyst for for
bellator so it's weird how it came full
circle but even after matt knocked him
out you know we talked about on the show
i see him in the back and
he could care less
he just knocked out fedor and he's like
yeah cool man like to him he's just this
skinny fat russian and some tight shorts
it's so disrespectful like no it's
it's fate or dude you have no idea it's
such a big deal but
uh matt talks about that that would be
the one fight that gets him out of
retirement and you know what's
interesting is federal fedor also wants
that fight which
i'd watch it yeah be here sign me up
then matt wants me to corner him i think
if he does fight oh that'll be dope yeah
which i would probably do
that's one i would probably do
so uh yeah that's available right now
flashback fight nights where we go and
watch the three most important fights in
a fighter's career
we're dropping
we're having a food truck this week
right case we have a we have a food
truck this week with michael chandler uh
one of my favorite people in the
business
and uh we give him some dope ass kicks
which he loved and you'll see him
rocking him and i love when i see the
fighters rocking the kicks like we saw
sugar shawn at the big uh pay-per-view
the last ufc pay-per-view and they got
him on the red carpet yes his pm blasted
out there he's rocking the
jbalvin jordan ones that i gave him i
mean they're gonna be a more perfect i
don't think we'll ever have a more
perfect shoe for a fighter than those
balvins than him
well we we have a pretty
special shoe for rampage when he's on i
think if
the street soldier this one's pretty up
pretty close up there but and then
obviously mitrione i gave him the yeezys
just because
he went out with someone to give a
flying frick about fashion and sad guy
so i was just going for a comfort and he
loves them man he wore them on the beach
warm on venice beach i'm sure they get
all scuffed up they change color which i
don't think you even noticed but that's
whatever um yeah it's my favorite shows
do so the plan with uh
the the whole thick boy
uh youtube show model business model is
uh we're dropping two food trucks a
month which we used to do on showtime
back in the day and then we dropped two
flashback fight nights a month and then
one fight companion and then four shop
shows
so we got a lot of work to do fellas but
we're booming man 127 000 subs going up
every month so appreciate you guys and
thanks for liking subscribing watching
everything that we do and i love you
guys for it man um
yeah but we had uh we had fights this
weekend obviously this saturday we have
a big ufc but last week um last saturday
we had a fight night and thank god uh it
started when it did because i was able
to watch the entire card from top to
bottom before i went and did my shows at
the punchline in sacramento
um you know
i i'm not saying anything that
especially the viewers of this show
didn't know that it's it was going to be
a tough task for bobby green um for
islam makachev
you know obviously
taking bobby green on short notice
supposed to fight uh dear use which i
don't think we're going to see that
fight um again unless stereo gets a win
over somebody else and then fights them
for the title um it'd be
very hard to deny
makachev a title shot after this
also after watching him against bobby
green who is a very vulnerable very
dangerous opponent him just
absolutely dismantling him fighting
smart
[Music]
i don't know how you can't deny i don't
know how you can deny him the title shot
i also don't know who is going to beat
him
i really don't you know it's all about
styles and matchups you know at the the
cremo creme de la creme up there at 55
you know and it just so happens the guy
that probably has the skill set to give
him the most issues would be charles
oliveira
so you know if
gachi were to get hurt or charles
delivered to get hurt mike jeff's gonna
be there you know ready to go
so that's how you could see him get a
tossed shot the quickest
but you know i i think there's no doubt
in my mind that he's gonna be the next
uh
fighter for the the title at 155.
you know you look at them against you
know a chandler or a gay chi you know
those are very very tough fights for
those gentlemen um
you know i think with charles oliveira
with the skill set he has on the ground
and um i would be curious to see that
especially with his striking you know he
is super dangerous on the feet as well
he would give moksha of the most issues
um i i do think that would be a tougher
puzzle for makchev to solve
just got to be honest with you fellas
and ladies i just don't the seven ladies
that are watching this i just don't feel
like uh there's too many uh
roadblocks for mokshev to become world
champion and he's a meteor champion for
quite some time he's very khabibis
uh but with better striking
you know i think khabib's wrestling
grappling is at an 11 out of 10. i think
islam is out of 10
and at that level at 55 i don't think
anybody's going to beat them
i was talking with
a friend of mine who knows the ufc has
watched the most
fights in the world of ever who works
for the ufc you can figure it out and i
told him you know i'm like yeah how
about mock chef man who the hell is
going to beat this guy
i say you should get a total shot next
and he's like yeah hopefully you know
he's in line just in case somebody falls
out he's ready to go i'm sure he is
this is what i would do
this is really what i would do
you know because the
the one thing that
you gotta
not worry about because i'm fine if the
game title shot but the outlier out
there that's just waiting and can jump
in and just kind of do whatever he wants
is conor mcgregor and he was talking
about a july return and he was telling
charles oliveira let why don't you wait
man because i'll be back in july
that's not happening
obviously charles oliveira and justin
gates are fighting very soon here
but if i'm the ufc
you know
let's you're you're praying to the the
fight gods that conor mcgregor gets to
win in his next fight otherwise it gets
very dicey very very dicey i don't know
how much long we can market his old
fights where he's winning stuff like
that isn't one in a hot mother trucking
second
so what i would do is i would invest in
my business and pay it forward and i'd
use all the eyeballs
of conor mcgregor and him fight makachev
on a major major pay-per-view it's a
terrible matchup for connor but there's
some history there right you look at
connor and the khabib and obviously
islam is very familiar with that and you
know conor could get back to his nasty
ways which some people love and
i don't know yeah i don't think connor's
scared of anybody i think connor would
sign tonight if they offered him that
fight
um
so
you know as a business model if you want
to get islam you know to that level that
khabib level and obviously khabib is a
massive massive star
and whether you want to submit it or not
a lot of that is because of his fight
with conor and all the drama with connor
and it kind of put him on the map
obviously him beyond defeat and
destroying people is what got him there
but what really
blew him the hell up was you know the
the animosity with conor mcgregor i
think we can
bank on that and use that and utilize
that with makachev
it makes a lot of sense i know mike chef
would take the fight i bet you mike
chav's gonna say hey man it's either
conor or title fight i'm not fighting
anybody else daryush is out i'm not
doing anything else it's connor i'm up
for that if you want to make me fight
one more time i'll fight o'connor in
july and then i want to fight for the
title after that if you do ufc it makes
a lot of sense
makes a lot of sense
but you're also tossing conor the worst
matchup [ __ ] possible and he hasn't
been very active and he's coming off a
broken leg
we'll see and then also you gotta think
is conor's team up for it you know i i
know connor's conor's definitely not
scared of islam jeff he's just not
that's what makes connor special and
it's well documented i'm a conor dick
writer we know this
but
his team would have to look at and go
dude you're coming off a leg injury
we you know we really need to win or we
gotta you know after this i don't know
like if the plans to fight three more
times or four more times
islam make the move man we got to get a
win this would be the toughest one to
get out of anyone charles oliveira is a
way better matchup for conor way better
so if i'm connor's team
if i'm missing management i say you know
hopefully charles beats justin gaichey
or even connor justin gates he's pretty
tasty too that's a tasty fight
so i i just don't want you guys to be
upset when you see connor jump the queue
and get a title shot because
you know why they're doing it and we all
don't mind it let's be honest there's
gonna be some purists out there upset
about it but i could really see it
happening i'm just saying there's
something to make it note of
where if
you know justin and charles beat each
other up and there's gonna be some time
off
and conor does want to fight in the
summer islam is gonna be ready to go in
the summer islam could use the eyeballs
not a terrible idea if you're an islam
fan
very literally the worst matchup
possible at 55 for conor
all right let's take a little break from
the fight shenanigans because ufc 272 is
this saturday we got a cowbest fight
companion 7 p.m pacific only on thick
boy it's covington versus maz vidal and
listen you want to watch it maybe watch
it with us maybe watch with your friends
maybe watch it with your stepmom i don't
care man but watch it and make bank with
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc and
they have a knockout offer for new
customers bet just one dollar on the
main event and get 100 in free bets no
matter what could be a first round
knockout a draw a double knockout no
matter the outcome you'll get paid man
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state yet you can still
feel the thrill of ufc 272 with
draftkings free to play pools everyone
can enter a free pool with ten thousand
dollars in prizes answer a handful of
questions like how long will the fight
last who will walk out the winner and
follow along to track your results
i i break it down on the show man but
this bet it's a flip a coin who do you
like better take out the odds i think
they have kobe has a minus 370 something
favorite take all that out man you take
out the odds because i think this fight
is impossible to decide who's gonna win
you have two former roommates two best
friends nobody knows each other better
than these two they know exactly what
the other one's gonna do what they're
good at what they do in the first round
what they do in the fifth round their
mentality it's gonna be who can cancel
all that noise out be professional stick
to a game plan i think if it goes to the
scorecards colby definitely wins if we
get a knockout it's definitely jorge so
you can bet on that stuff but it's a
great fight flip the coin download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code shobb s-e-h-a-u-b
throw down just one dollar on the ufc
272 main event kobe kempton versus jorge
masvidal and get one hundred dollars in
free bets no matter the outcome
that's coach schaub this saturday at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc
must be 21 or older minimum age and
location requirements vary by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for a full list of
requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources void where
prohibited minimum 5 deposit gambling
problem call 100 gambler in tennessee
call or text the tennessee red line at
in connecticut 1-800-889-9789
888-789-7777
or visit
ccpg.org chat in new york call
8778 hope and y or text hope and why
if you're still listening after all that
use draftking sportsbook
bet on it watch the cowbest fight
campaign live at 7pm pacific on the
thick boy network only bet on the main
event and make money one dollar
one freaking dollar all right and you
can get 100 dollars in free bets no
matter what the outcome is ufc 272 is
this saturday watch it make bank bro use
promo code sch aub
man there's a lot of reasons why you're
not sleeping right there's a lot of
reasons maybe it's today's politics
maybe your girl broke up with it baby
you're watching your favorite show 1883
and was the saddest finale i've ever
seen in my life and i didn't sleep great
last night and i cried a lot because i
watch american idol whatever it is man
yeah well the one problem you can solve
is your mattress yep you might be
sleeping on a bad mattress toss out all
the stuff i just mentioned it might be
your terrible mattress and that's why at
my house i only have helix mattresses my
mom comes in town this weekend with my
ants they won't stay anywhere else it's
not because they love me it's because
they love my mattress all i have is
helix sleep mattresses that's right
helix has the mattress just for you
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress just for your thick ass
if you like matches that are really soft
or firm you sleep on your side you're
back you sleep hot cold whatever it is
man helix there's a mattress that's
built just for you huge sleep was even
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2019 2020 by gq and
wired magazine listen i sleep like a
baby with helix sleep mattresses i can't
get rid of my in-laws i can't get rid of
my mom my dad my brother like oh we love
you but they don't they love my helix
mattress i know the gig just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with the perfect
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk free all right they'll even
pick it up if you don't love it but you
will so don't worry about that helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattresses
all right
orders and free pillows for the
listeners and viewers of this episode of
the shop show helixsleep.com
that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200 off
so we'll see man
but uh yeah outside islam you know
connor vs charles fantasic
connor vs justin gaichy fantastic
um
so let's see what they want to do but i
would love to hear who you guys think is
going to be mike jeff
i don't know
i just don't know the guy's so dominant
and you know you talk to
the likes of you know uh a josh thompson
um you know a luke rockhold a dc you
know these are my friends they say oh oh
you haven't seen anything dude this guy
inside the gym is a savage and he's his
thing is just getting used to the lights
and being a maid event and getting all
this attention so he's still fighting
pretty shy pretty conservative like what
like yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] it's like the
the the hamza [ __ ] man i know every show
i bring up hamza i'm just he's just
terrifying it is what it is man and i am
so
on the train for hamzat and makuchev
listen in five years the entire ufc's be
ran by russians and dykstanians
get ready
we all need to learn how to pronounce
the names
starting with me
get ready man
so uh yeah so i thought mark jeff looked
fantastic you know for bobby green
um
i don't think there's anything hang your
head about man he took the final short
notice you know it's a complete
nightmare of a match up for you you've
been in there with some of the best your
guy the ufc can always rely on i don't
think you know you you lose any
any ground with ufc i think they give
you a fun fight next you know i think if
anything anyone who knows a sport is you
know proud of you and i think that
you know it's just up from here man you
know you fight you fight literally i
think
i think a lot of people agree with me i
think time will prove this i think you
fought the best 155 on the planet not
named khabib who's still active and he
did on short notice okay
so you got taken down all right
that's happens all good dude you took a
chance um you know i told you guys don't
best don't bet your you know mortgage on
it and don't bet you know your gas money
on it but it wouldn't be a bad bet to
put on bobby green hopefully you guys
um didn't bet too much on that fight but
you know it's worth the risk and uh
macho just fought smart and realized the
only way he could lose is by you know an
explosive shot or something like that so
he negated those problems and took him
down and punched him out pretty smart
pretty smart man let me see that
wrestler cartoon because there's some
mvps on there obviously mockingjabs is
easy to give a mvp there but
and they didn't give them a fight night
bonus like dude to my [ __ ] a guy in a
last minute replacement um
uh that wellington uh turman looked
fantastic i thought he was for sure
gonna lose in the second round i thought
uh he had some quid in him but he ended
up pulling off that slick ass armbar uh
by far the best by the night which i
thought was a robbery i i really and
dude i don't throw that term around
very very
very
very rarely do i throw that term robbery
around but i thought uh that priscilla
versus the yi young kim that right
young kim i thought ji young kim won
that fight pretty easily i know she you
know her she got marked up more and it
looked like priscilla was landing these
big shots then you look at the the
replay like well they're kind of grazing
shots the knee really messed her up um
but you know you even look at the
numbers and
uh that yi young kim definitely won that
fight i thought for sure thought for
sure man yeah thought for sure she won
that fight she got robbed ben but uh the
priscilla girl hits like a [ __ ] mack
truck
it's interesting right because it shows
you
where mixed martial arts is at i mean
there's just such a discrepancy in
talent especially in the women's
flyweight division because 18 months ago
i think she was an addict she was she
was like doing drugs and [ __ ] in brazil
and then found fighting and she just
started fighting 18 months ago and now
she's in the biggest organization in the
world
me and my brother talking about that's
like you know being a drug addict and
like man i only get sober and then 18
months later you're the starting point
guard for the lakers then no other sport
could you you just can't shows you where
fighting's kind of at especially in the
women's divisions it's just you know she
also has a certain set of skills which
is impressive and hits like a mack truck
and great elbows and has the right
training and i think she's a purple belt
now which um i would assume she trained
before 18 months otherwise we got to
question that purple belt if you had in
18 months but uh beaver purple belt
after the fight
it was a little weird because there's no
grappling whatever um
you know at least she got it but uh
i just didn't think she won that fight
and he fasted and he fasted and then uh
that arm and say his last name for me
chance zarukian surukian
there's a t in front of it makes no
sense but however you guys want to do it
man uh armin cerukian is an absolute
savage what's interesting about him is
his only loss is stomach
before they both got to the ufc so he's
hoping you know he climbs up in the
rankings and gets another shot at
makachev but he looked fantastic the
elbow that he landed was filthy as [ __ ]
um
but overall it's a good card man fun
card
fun card fight of the night priscilla
versus that young kim for sure
performance tonight want to determine
that makes sense and then sarookian
makes sense
two studs but that's sarukin keep an eye
on him he is a problem handsome devil
too bodied up dude
body the hell up
uh but i'm excited for this big
pay-per-view on saturday man ufc 272
there ain't nothing
like a big pay-per-view especially when
it's a freaking dramatic main event two
guys where there's animosity talking
about guys who live together two they
used to be best friends nobody knows
colby come to him better than horry
mozzarell and nobody knows jorge mazda
all better than kobe covington now they
can't stand each other finally we're
getting to see this fight i think the
narrative that some people are painting
that you know jorge maswall needs this
man you know he's long in the tooth he's
like
because he lost kamara hooswin that
makes sense before that he was on a
[ __ ] starch fest against some really
talented dudes yeah if you look at
mozart all so you know people are like
man you know he's long on the tooth
maybe he doesn't have it you know when
you get knocked out you know is this
really a good fight for mazda doll
so he got knocked out by camaro okay
he got knocked out by camaro
and then he lost to come on via decision
hey tell you guys kamar is a pound for
brown best in the world we have right
now the best we have he beats everybody
just because you lost to the very very
best doesn't mean you're on the backside
of your career in any facet because
before that he
molly whopped nate diaz beat there's
some 10-8 rounds there and then he
absolutely posterized ben askren then
before that this is what started the
whole
mazladol train that made him this huge
pay-per-view star he flew down to london
fought a young line in darren till and
absolutely flatlined them
ko home run
so went till
aspirin diaz then you run into usman and
there's nothing to hang your head on
losing to usman he's going to beat
everybody i don't know who's going to be
newsmen the only thing i could see
giving them issues right now is hamzad
that's it who knows
i love how the narrative oh shop says
who's been scared of hamza i don't think
why didn't i what i'm just saying
stylistically
harms out right now looks like he could
be
an issue for everybody in division
including newsmen doesn't mean oozman
can't beat him doesn't mean usman's
mentality isn't stronger than hamzad's
i'm just saying i'd love to see that
fight i don't know who's going to win
i'm a huge kumarusaman fan he's a
pound-for-pound goat for a reason he
absolutely destroys people so it's like
come on dude
um
but yeah i don't get the narrative of
you know colby you know he's younger and
he he lost come on
they both lost to camaro so camaro's
hands down the best dude outside it's
like camaron and everybody else and
everybody else all about styles and
match-ups and the other thing i think
about this fight is
like i told you nobody knows colby
better nobody knows mozart all better
than than those two guys
and that makes for such an interesting
fight because remember
colby used to help moz vidal with his
wrestling
mazda used to help kobe with his
striking so they know what the other one
likes to do to a t
so that takedown that
kobe usually gets or you know the way he
gets in on takedowns or the way he gets
in with you know his striking his combos
and you know that pacing
might as well seen it all man he was
there from the jump he was there at the
the origin story of kobe covington
before colby was kobe kobe was corning
him they were training partners
roommates nobody knows each other better
so to me
you got to throw everything you you you
got throw everything out that you know
about these two because they know each
other so freaking well
it's such a tough fight to call
my
my heart thinks that moswell can pull
this off and get a k and get a finish i
don't know why couldn't tell you
the the odds would disagree with you i
think draftking says colby uh you know
minus 300 for a reason yeah minus 335.
jorge miles plus 260. not a terrible bet
to bat on horizon all again these are
you know if you're going to bet on a guy
who's a plus 260 there's a reason to
plus 260. these odds makers think that
colby isn't going there
kobe ain't finishing jorge
but also the the one caveat of all this
is horry got flatlined the last time he
entered the octagon how does that affect
a veteran of jorge mosbydoll he's been
around the game forever but he's never
been flatlined like that ever ever ever
so we don't know how this could affect
tory uh has he lost confidence is united
can be as wild which makes him special
uh does he know that any time he
pressured forward on kobe kobe would
take him down so he doesn't want to
spend the you know the majority of the
fight on his back so there's these
things where this is such to me this is
a gimme fight meaning it's literally
whoever you like more bet on him those
odds should to me do not i don't care
that colby's at minus 300. take it out
of this you take all that out of this we
don't know how what it's going to look
like the household going to react after
being flatlined how's colby going to
react knowing that mazwell knows all his
tricks and his takedowns and his
pressure and he knows how to deal with
it he knows what gets to colby he knows
that you know the the chinks in colby's
armor who's gonna you know
be able to mentally
deal with that stuff better that's who's
gonna win this fight so who put your
money on whoever you like better forget
about the odds for these experts quote
unquote there's no experts in the fight
game but these experts
they don't [ __ ] know what's going on
here it's whoever can
you know imply their will and really you
know get the other guy to do what you
know he's not used to doing and i you
know there's a lot of experience with
mazdal man and he's very explosive i
would be willing to bet if this fight
ends in a finish it's going to be
mosvidal
so mozville if you pick moswell to win
you win by finish that's where you make
some money can he do it apps are
freaking lutely
odds are against them 100 percent you
know but kobe come covington
and here's the other caveat where you're
like who should i bet on dude i'm saying
bet on the guy that you think is going
to win because these are take the odds
out of it don't even look at that just
put your money on the guy because colby
compton is the best welterweight in the
world not named kumar usman he's had
these great fights with camaro you know
great phenomenal fights with camaro
it just so happens
kobe was born a certain time the same
time kamara was so if tomorrow take
tomorrow the picture kobe is your
reigning champion dude
it sucks for colby that's the way it was
with gus finn he would be your reigning
world champion for many many times over
there wasn't a jon jones there you know
let's take another little break from the
fight drama in this world of fighting
because listen
people want different jobs different
careers all right you want to change
your career there's never been a better
time to become a programmer my dad's
programmer papa's a programmer they know
what they're doing man they never have
to worry about getting a job because
they got a certain set of skills they
know how to code and they do it on their
own terms all right we're living in a
fast changing world one of the best ways
to succeed in it is to learn how to code
try code academy today and see where
coding can take you whether you're
starting from scratch you know what
you're doing or super advanced
codecademy can help you reach your
coding goals all right over 50 million
people already know that codecademy is
the best way to learn to code all right
because codecademy not only teaches you
job-ready coding skills but also helps
you build unique projects for your
portfolio earn certificates even prep
for technical interviews we got you man
learn at your own pace get qualified for
in-demand jobs choose what to learn from
building basic websites to ai and
everything else you could ever want man
get instant feedback your code is tested
as soon as you submit it so you always
know if you're on the right track all
right land your dream job in web
development programming computer science
data science tons more shoot maybe think
boy hired where he's looking for people
who's good at coding joined over 50
million people learn to code with
codecademy and see where coding can take
you get 15 off your codecademy pro
membership when you go to
codeacademy.com use promo code shop
s-h-a-u-b that's promo code shop at
codecademy.com
to get 15 off codecademy pro the best
way to learn to code
that is c o d e c a d e m y dot com
promo code shop
i love this fight i love the drama i
love the back story you know it's the
first time in quite some time you got
two guys who aren't title holders you
know headlining a a
pay-per-view and there's a good reason
for that two superstars um say what you
about colby i know obviously though
trump the maggot stuff
clearly it's an act and so you got two
polarizing completely different guys
colby compton 100 is an act we've been
over this joy mazdale is as real as they
as they get that's why you love him so
you have just these two polar opposites
and they used to be best [ __ ] friends
and they hate each other now i would
assume whoever wins i hope that they're
cool and give give each other a hug
after the fight they've been through
some [ __ ] man i really hope they're cool
after the fight the issue is
as kobe goals that goes down this road
which i don't like you know i think it's
uh you know it's that this this newer
generation where they just take things
too far i'm all about trash talk and
hype in the fight but when you go
personal with it and you talk about
jorge's a bad dad or jorge's
ex-girlfriend or ex-wife or the hell you
was talking about that's where i'm like
i'm out yeah i don't i don't partake in
that man i don't need that to buy the
fight yet these guys skill sets sell the
fight
the history of you guys being roommates
and training partners and living
together and training together that
sells the fight i don't need you to talk
about is being a father and you know
being a
you know a dad and
you know his ex-girlfriend that stuff's
just it's below the belt no pun intended
it's just
it's just too much man that doesn't make
anybody feel good but it's a great main
event take that out of its great main
event kobe obviously is ruffling
feathers trying to get in jorge's head
because he knows if who listen
whichever one of these guys fights on
emotion is definitely going to lose you
got to be strategic you got to be smart
you got to be professional and not let
the outside noise get to you because you
can make mistakes and both these guys
are so good if you make a mistake you're
going to lose so it's whoever comes in
with a professional approach and usually
colby's that guy but with their
background i don't know i don't know
that's why i'm telling you put money on
who everything's going to win don't
worry about the odds in the co-main
event is this right jen i heard this is
a five-round fight is that right which
would be strange for a non-title fight
co-main event
how how do they decide
if it's five rounds
yeah
will remain a five round because it was
supposed to be a fight night
main event for five rounds so they just
remember they moved it yeah so i'm
assuming because they moved like let's
leave it at five yeah i'm all for it i'm
in say less
because then johnny walker and uh jamal
hill got put up to the main event uh i'm
all for this
rafael dos sanchos rafael physique uh
haafio
and hafiel crime man rafael and hotfield
crime
uh top fight for dos sanjos dos anjos if
you if you look at his track record he's
following some tough times you know his
last fight he won against paul felder um
via split decision and if you remember
paul felder took that fight in a very
very short notice
so you know
it's not that impressive to be to paul
felder who took on short notice who's
been a suit and tie and then decided to
jump in there and save the card and it
was a split decision that was a great
fight fight of the night so
uh paul feller obviously phenomenal
fighter but in short notice
you know so you know
you look at dos sanjos you know he lost
to colby lost camaro he beat kevin lee
lost leon edwards lost lost to michael
chiesa
you know so he's losing the
the top guys uh jess is not a top guy
but he's still pretty freaking good um
this could be a tough fight for your boy
dos angels and i he's the nicest one of
the nice guys in the ufc absolutely love
him he was always great to me i thought
in brazil he's the only guy who had my
back and gave me rides and took me to
places where i could eat where they went
poison my food so i love dos sanjo's man
absolutely love him i just don't see him
win this fight if he can get it down
we're talking about a different story i
think that the grappling is going to be
how does fazeev
deal with uh dos sancho's grappling
on the feet
fazeev is an absolute nightmare of a a
problem to solve for dos anjos so
you know and fizzy's also coming off
that brad riddle
ko spinning wheel kick victory which was
performance of the night that fight was
freaking close against brad riddle
freaking close man that knockout was
phenomenal but
we remember the knockout but remember
that fight was very close but
um this is a huge step up for fazeev ufc
obviously believes in faziv they think
you can get it done i think you can get
it done it's a tough night in the office
for dos anjos unless you can get them
down and get them down often it's gonna
be a tough night in the office for him
good card though man i love that that's
five rounds barboza bryce mitchell again
barboza has fallen tough times i think
bryce mitchell gets that done
um with his grappling obviously on the
feet bryce mitchell is going to be in
a world of trouble but i don't see this
fight staying on the feet too long kevin
holland uh
the brazilian
cowboy alex oliveira uh you know i think
oliveira's gonna have his hands full
there kevin holland gets done
and then you know you say what you want
about greg hardy but he's always
entertaining the guy always brings it so
you know i like when he's on the cards i
i think you can always count on an
entertaining fight win or loss so
whenever he's on uh this is just a
matter this there's a few
fights uh really there's
well
i mean um
depending how colby fights
you got a lot of gr wrestler grappler
versus striker
basically the entire main card is
grappler for striker so whoever imposes
their will gets their game plan done um
you know if it's the grapplers you're
gonna have a long freaking card it's
gonna be a long ass fight companion if
the grapplers just keep getting
takedowns and riding out decision
decisions
i don't think that's gonna happen i
think these grapplers have their hands
full so you know greg hardy the furthest
thing away from a grappler on the card
against uh sergey s
spivak who's obviously you know fancied
himself with grappler i think greg
carter's gonna knock him out kevin
holland charles oliveira that one's more
you know kevin holland can freaking
wrestle but strike two that's probably
the closest matchup as far as grappler
striker they can both fancy themselves
strikers barboza bryce mitchell that is
completely grappler for striker um doe
sanjo's physique although dos sanchos
can strike he's definitely gonna get
that fight down and then colby
definitely a grappler jorge mazdal
definitely a striker so
um if these grapplers have it their way
you could have a ton of decisions in a
boring card i don't think that's gonna
happen i don't but
you know you never know sometimes that
happens and it's a nightmare even though
and i love grappling i absolutely love
grapple i know what's going on but i
know for the fans out there he was like
come on dude but i i truly think you
know
you're gonna get some big knockouts man
brian kelleher our boys fighting yeah
boom tim elliott that's a great one
dustin jacoby jesus christ
can we get him a [ __ ] some shine you
get him on the first flight of the night
a veteran and uh dustin jacoby come on
man
uh
you really good fight women's
strawweight marina rodriguez young
uh is a great fight
he almost had some chinese on chinese
crime if yon would have won her last one
but she didn't but i'm excited for this
card man
what do you got jen alrighty
oh so the fights
this one as well gay garment saucy and
vanderbilt yes poor freaking ass aston
austin vander ford man he you know going
into this fight you know and you're
fighting gayard musasi the the biggest
big dick energy guy in the game
it's well documented as the biggest dick
in the game he's also the champion
definitely the biggest stake is the
champion
uh you know i'd love to see it he has
that big big sean energy do you see big
sean's league nude
dude
bro
dude he says it wasn't his but also it's
definitely his
he he has a nintendo switch so
he's holding the nintendo switch like
this the dick is here
it's longer than nintendo switch so what
i like to do is i like to take my son's
antenna switch i measured that yeah
it's over nine inches what the f
damn nickname is big sean he's not big
over nine he's a small guy
very impressive very impressive best
leak i've seen in a while oh my gosh uh
but mousasi is right up there with the
big dick energy
you know it's such a shame that bellator
and ufc uh can't figure things out and
you know because
mousasi versus izzy
fantastic fight
fantastic fight musashi has a set of
skills that
could pose a problem for is he does he
beat him i don't know but i'd love to
see it which we never well poor austin
uh vanderford though going this fight
he's like you know i'm gonna get on my
girl's shadow you know i'm not gonna be
referred to as mr paige van zand anymore
and then you just go and then get
starched yeah
damn dude and he's never lost it's his
first loss and it was a bad one it was a
really bad loss yeah now i think he was
concussed from the sprawl if you look at
the replay when he shoots in mousasi
sprawls so hard and he falls on his head
and that it wasn't a he didn't get hit
with a knee or an elbow or a punch there
the sprawl is what [ __ ] him up bad bad
bad bad musashi's such a savage dude so
goddamn good he couldn't touch him man
you wouldn't love to see mousasi versus
izzy
and who starts to get to the mic he said
i'm the best middleweight in the world
and i'm like
maybe
love to see it we never will
but yeah i just feel bad for vanderford
because obviously i'm sure he gets a lot
of heat you know he's married to paige
van zandt who's an absolute dime of all
dimes she's the queen of mma and you
know they have their whatever their
version of only fans they're posting
pictures and
you know so he
he was like yeah i'm gonna get out of
the shower my girl and then you just get
starched okay he's probably waking up to
like god damn it you know
like put yourself in his shoes this
morning
now granted you are waking up you're
waking up next to paige vanzant so life
ain't that bad austin you got this buddy
did he post anything yeah he did uh
he made a statement afterwards
here it is uh humble and victory and
defeat congrats
on willow and victory last night wasn't
my night but i'm thankful that this will
only make me a better fighter agree dude
thank you to the friends family and fans
support me we'll be back but another
thing in my team thank you all my
teammates best gym in the world and last
but most important thank you my loving
wife paige vanzant who's there for me
forever always i'm good and motivated to
just get back to the gym yeah dude do
your thing man you got this buddy yeah
that's a tough super tough task for him
yeah they i just you know
i don't know if you ever beat the
mousasi
so mousasi had this uh press conference
afterwards and he was talking about
conor mcgregor i guess conor mcgregor
and him have gone back back and forth
back in the days i didn't know this
either i don't know they talk smack to
each other and uh this is what he said
and it seems pretty real too
oh because conor was in the crowd yeah a
lot of those guys were fighting because
this was in dublin right
that crowd's insane dude the best dude
with that in australia but probably
dublin's the best though right best
place i've performed dublin hands down
okay guys you were on aerial hawaii show
yesterday and you were talking about it
an old it not foe but somebody don't
like it conor mcgregor i overheard him
saying it's awesome to rip your head off
before he walked out who said that
connor
i talked to his coach
and my brother is here you know
he would have died i swear to god so you
know
i'm not [ __ ] wrong with that guy
i don't know that i got nothing against
the guy you know if he wants to come you
can't come and uh i'm not kidding she
clarified he said for austin vanderferg
to rip your head off enough to break
your head off oh it's lucky for him
because he's short
i don't think conor wants that heat but
also it's serious yeah yeah yeah
mousasi is the absolute monster no you
know kind of don't want that heat it's
also what's interesting too about this
you know musashi just wins a huge world
title fight and the news is conor
mcgregor that's how powerful conor
mcgregor exactly
all right this is uh the opening odds of
makachev
versus oliveira a massive favorite
massive favorite so it's right here
following his first round
uh route of bobby green
minus 415 that's insulting
i wow
yeah like i said i you know just from my
perspective
stylistically
i think charles oliver matches up the
best with him as far as giving the most
issues
but a plus 345 for charles oliveira
yeah that's not so dude
but again i i don't know who's gonna
beat him i just don't i really don't
then charles oliveira is slightly
betting favorite minus 155 against
justin gaichi
that's a toss-up i mean plus 135 minus
155 that's that's like flipping a coin i
just you know i i i don't know who the
hell is going to be mock jeff i get i
get those big odds but jesus christ so
disrespectful
so disrespectful
all right so diego sanchez says he
joined eagle fc
even though he was taking a pay cut i
guess he would have like 75 000 more if
he did bkfc
but he wanted to because he's a martial
artist he wanted to make sure that he
represents mma
i was going to get paid 75 000 more to
do bkfc but being the diego sanchez that
i am i believe in myself and all the
skills and knowledge and the wisdom that
i've attained over this course the last
20 years the way my career ended in the
ufc was not diego sanchez fashion that
was orchestrated by my handler
and so i really wanted to truly finish
mixed martial arts legacy and career my
way diego sanchez intuition
working through whatever i've got to
work through but training smart doing my
martial arts when everyone thinks they
get a fair yeah it's tough
because yeah he's fighting uh
yeah between kevin lee it's a tough
fight for diego i like it that diego's
like nah i'm i'm not done with mma yet
i'm not ready to go to the spare knuckle
yet
it'd be not gonna be tough for him man
75 grand more though
yeah yeah i know
i know
it's short-sighted though i think you
know yeah that bare knuckle man
especially for an old
old veteran and diego you know you might
make 75 more grand now but you can't use
it in your grappling which he is a
mantra of a grappler you know so i think
in the
looking at the long run depending how
much he wants to fight the eagle fc
definitely the smart choice
and speaking of bkfc i guess triller
just bought a majority stake in them
so
they said it's going to be the same
thing as normal but they just have way
more resources and more money yeah
that's all that is and they're going
after ingano once he's like free they
want to go after ngano ah yeah yeah i
get it
i get it
i get it
you know i don't want that for ghana
as much as i love bkfc yeah i'd love for
the ufc to figure out their deal with
francis and
you know partake in the marketing of the
tyson fury fight
you know what what heavyweights would
francis fight
you know
who the who in the hell
is gonna sacrifice their brain health
and fight francis and ghana with bare
freaking knuckles dude
i don't i mean who's he gonna fight he's
just knocking dudes out left and right
you know yeah
yeah i'd be very surprised if francis
goes that route
the you know the boxing rod is probably
the best yes
all right so this is the sad part about
this is all in the news obviously the
russian invasion of ukraine
so this can actually affect um fighters
now so
well you can't fly yeah so the uk is
actually stopping people from getting
their visas if they're part of
you know here let me actually show you
the what she can't fly at all
i'll get that too yeah the like the the
way
the world is reacting to the russia
trying to invade ukraine they're not
allowing russian planes to land in any
other country so if you're a russian
fighter you're gonna have to figure
something out
yeah so the london card has a few
russian fighters and even our guy jack
shore he's fighting someone that has
that
i guess you know some lineage so he
might not be able to make that fight
either so that kind of sucks but this is
the home secretary for the uk saying
that i've canceled a visa
of belarusian men's basketball team who
are due to play in newcastle tomorrow
night the uk will not welcome the
national sports team of those countries
who are complicit and putin's unprovoked
illegal invasions of ukraine i agree
with them it sucks because
if you're that basketball team if you're
one of these fighters
you know you you don't have any control
of any of this man i'm sure if you ask
them like we don't want to go no one
wants war it's putin's crazy ass so it's
like we have nothing to do with it but
now you're seeing repercussions it's
gonna you know
this russian [ __ ] rolls downhill man
it's not good it's so sad man it's such
a bummer man who goes to war in 2022
it's not senseless it's so
but boy russia's in for a surprise
aren't they they they forgot how badass
ukrainians are the [ __ ]
fighting hell yeah if you're between the
ages of 18 and 40 can't leave the
country you got to go pick up a gun and
fight and everybody's on board yeah you
got the glitch goes let's go to the
picture of the clutch goes yeah have you
seen the picture of loma chambers over
here dude that lomachenko is a
millionaire
it has a [ __ ] place on south beach it
was like they're doing what this is how
much of a badass ukrainians are he's
like they're doing what
dude get this [ __ ] suntan oil off me
i'm [ __ ] head of ukraine get the guns
ready get my fatigues ready yeah look at
him dude
it's so awesome
sucks but it's so awesome that they're
like the klitschko's him
uh even the bellator champ that's
supposed to fight michael venom page he
also went back to fight they're just
this you could never discredit how tough
ukrainians are man yeah i think putin
did
you know the the sad thing is is let me
go pound for pound ukrainians are
beating the [ __ ] out of them it's a
numbers game it's only a matter of time
no matter how many russians they take
out it's a matter of time before they
take over the capital
it's heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking it was weird
watching the was i was watching the uh
some awards last night for actual sag
sag your boy's part of seg but um
boy smart sag got it uh working on a
movie called um what movie do i have
collector tax collector part of sag so
be cool
um
i didn't get my invite to the award show
which is very strange but that's fine
but it's weird when the where you know
there's this
war going on and these ashes like you
know
you know what we do is so special i'm
like holy [ __ ] you guys are out to lunch
yeah actors you know yeah it's so weird
to watch that's weird it's just what are
you gonna do it's like
from their perspective you know it's
like there's nothing they can do they
you know they that you know
entertainment does provide such an
outlet and you know shapes our society
you know that they do have a very
important job
you know but it's just
i don't know just they're you know
they're in la they're receiving these
awards and it's just like it did feel
really weird at least they did say
really nice things about what's going on
in the world yeah some of them did some
did but just it's just
man i'll bring up some pictures from the
bombings oh my god [ __ ] ukraine
that'll blow your mind
so terrible
terrible terrible terrible
okay um moving past this jamal hill who
just beat johnny walker and had that
really almost viral ko i guess uh johnny
walker's wife or fiance
posted this and it's basically she's
getting dms
and messages from people showing like
doing memes of johnny walking knocked
out right which is just freaking sad
sleepy wanker you got a weak man and
that weird
it's like what the hell dude
okay so that's you know you just you
just got people that
you know her people hurt other people so
the way social media works if you're
gonna unfortunately part of the game if
you subscribe to this world where
everybody has an opinion you're dealing
with a lot of mental unstable people
where
they've never taken a chance in their
life with anything so with a guy like
johnny walker even though he's following
some hard times
he's taking chances so when he fails it
validates them and their feelings so
they want to capitalize on it and go see
what happens when you take a chance how
shitty is it to dm someone's wife or
girl that kind of [ __ ] though like it's
just it just sounds like you're just
terrible yeah i mean even meg the stalin
who's absolutely gorgeous so talented
she posted the other day she's like i
get this every day multiple times a day
and this guy like man someone needs to
find mega stallion shooter
she's like i don't know why i get this i
get it every day i do it every day
that's what you know with as great as
social media is
for some angles and especially for what
i do you know lets people know i'll be
in uh you know nashville in two weeks
and you know you promote that stuff the
dark side of it is you know everybody
has an opinion you got some people
some real bad people out there and their
only objectives cause chaos it's to hurt
yeah which is terrible to hurt you know
so
yeah it's it's not healthy for a lot of
people to be on there man it's like pete
davidson you know obviously
you know he's dealing with literally the
two most famous people on the planet not
named putin right now and kim kardashian
kanye and when connie starts making fun
of him connie has a huge huge fan base
so these people are going to troll them
he even he named skeet he goes if you
see pete on the street yell out skeet
people are doing that man so for pete
davidson he's been off instagram for a
variety of reasons right
but
you know aussie pizza and i i i do i
love pete i adore pete i think he's a
talented comic and he's always been nice
to me and god bless a man and he has
something about him and i think people
are triggered you know look at the women
that he slept with and you know his past
dating history and now he's dating kim
kardashian
he got on instagram why he decided i
think to promote his movie or whatever
it's fine
but he was on there for a day and then
jumped off i was like yeah like a lot of
people think kanye ran him off i'm sure
kanye's influence ran him off i you know
i don't think it's fair to say he just
decided to get out on his own because he
got on there for a reason but he goes uh
i decided to get off instagram i'll come
back someday but and if it it really
connected he goes
uh it doesn't make me feel good because
my life outside social media is lit as
[ __ ] we think i was like yeah dude
you're on saturday live everybody loves
you dude everybody that knows pete loves
him
dude you're sleeping with kim kardashian
you have dope fashion you have money
you're torn you're selling tickets
people that know you love you
why subscribe to it pete why would you
get on there dude see him just being
like my life outside this is dope as
[ __ ]
but it's just like these angry trolls
and you know pete is this guy and they
don't think he deserves this or should
be with this girl you know he's crushed
us there live so it's like why why play
the game pete why you know why why play
the game dude i don't get it
you know
but it's a shame people have to deal
with any of it yeah
well bringing it back to this so jamal
hill saw that and then he made this
video which i thought was super dope
yo
bro look
i do what i do for the entertainment of
the fans
and the love of the sport bro
and whenever i'm successful
you know what i mean and and
another fighter i mean i get and i get a
knockout and i get these have these
moments that y'all like
but don't use that time to dog somebody
bro
yeah i mean
i've i've received i've lost so i've
received
i mean the the ridicule and the things
that come with that you know what i mean
and i understand that people are
ignorant but i can only imagine how
y'all doing my mans right now bro that
[ __ ] ain't cool bro that [ __ ] ain't cool
think about if that was you think about
if that was your kid
yeah i mean you can't though your
brother
come on bro
at some point we gotta draw the line bro
where's the lion at bro where do we
become where where do we still be able
to come out and look each other in the
face
young man
and still be people
yeah i mean
he got knocked out it happens people
have been knocked out many times before
and most of you [ __ ] just
talking whenever put yourself in a
position you run like a little [ __ ] you
hide in the house i'd have seen y'all
before
y'all cowards bro
so for y'all to sit there and do this to
this man who steps out against the best
in the [ __ ] world
you know what i'm saying
people who train night and day to do
that
y'all run from basic ass people
cut it out
[ __ ] cowards
i mean sitting behind the screen talking
get out that man inbox he's still eating
he still got money
you probably broke sit in your [ __ ]
mom's basement
bro
hey you a fan of mine you came to my
page to see me to see me do that just
see me win and for you to go and dog
people get the [ __ ] on bro cuz i don't
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] bro leave that man
alone let him get back to his drawing
bro get back to his crap cause y'all
gonna keep watching for him putting his
body in all of that [ __ ] yeah i'm being
stopped i'm a bigger fan of jamal hill
now we are getting my food truck
yeah you know with these guys especially
ufc guys or any celebrities you know
maybe because i'm older but you know a
lion doesn't care what the sheep say
these people are just sheeps
you know it's just this sheep mentality
it's this loser mentality
and they're gonna be the loudest on the
internet for the most part really not
even the loudest the the positive
people always win and the people that
are taking chances always win and that's
why they have all these followers
like you'll notice you'll never see a
hater with a ton of followers you never
see a hater with a an influence or
selling merch or do because they can't
because no one really [ __ ] with that
because it's just you know you're you're
just these losers man you know so for
jamal hill to
you know let people know it's it's it's
uh it's pretty cool man yeah yeah i'm a
huge fan of him yeah big time fan now
but yeah these these fighters these
young fighters and i don't know how old
johnny walker is but
dude you've never cared before what the
loser said man that's why you're johnny
walker dude the shitty part is it's not
it's to his girl like what are you doing
like
because they know john walker's probably
not seeing it yeah the best thing gives
to the girl but so it's just like you're
just like imagine the biggest loser in
your school just the negative kid if
you're walking down the hallway like
cool shoes like
excuse me
you're the worst kid in the school dude
you wouldn't give a [ __ ]
but now all those losers have a place to
you know like oh i'm a loser you're a
loser let's get together you know so
they they can they have a tribe you know
he also said hurt people hurt people so
yeah who knows what they're going
through but still stop doing it it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
it's just not a winner's mentality you
know you're never gonna get out of your
mom's basement doing this stuff
you gotta get out of there get a girl do
something do something do it challenge
yourself yeah yeah create your own
content man do your own [ __ ] whatever it
is man yeah
all right so this was uh during a pfl
challenger series and this dude's
eyeball popped out of his socket
that's not good yeah so i'll show you
this
well you'll see how his eye looks what
happened to his eye i'll show you just a
second
this fight is over because of damage to
the left eye yeah cause his [ __ ] eyes
pop out of the socket
so it was a punch that landed and then i
guess it cracked his orbital
and then he tried to blow his nose oh
and then his eyeball
jesus christ yeah but no surgery needed
he'll be fine
but that's no surgery thank god man yeah
uh this is the air pressure in the plane
could move the fracture yeah that's not
good yeah from florida arizona okay so
you're not gonna drive there
dr said martin should not fly home from
florida arizona def after a while
sparta's team could be driving home
cross country definitely drive dude yeah
hope he's all right jesus christ so you
want to be a fighter huh
all right so we're still we're still
getting the fight but it's going to be
moved go over took sarah yuri prashaka
prashaska
prahashka
yeah
274 to uc 275 in june i'll take it and
they didn't there's no reason they
didn't say what it was but it just had
to be moved i know year he's ready to go
i just saw him at the tyson thing he was
in shape jesus christ that dude is in
shape thin dude and that outfit that he
wore was interesting too yeah looks like
24-hour fitness trainer you look dope in
shape man yeah
all right so paul daly this is his
retirement fight and they're giving them
andre kreshkov who just broke that guy's
ribs
fighting for paul daley yeah so porsche
is a monster
so london in may that's dope though
that's cool the bell tours give him that
retirement fight yeah
but that isn't crazy tough fight yes
this i thought was really cool too shiny
aoki and uh yoshiro akama sexy cool yeah
japanese legends at ones look at
akiyama's tits he's still
super rich and tanned
it's i mean he has to be the best
looking asian dude of all time i mean
he's one of those one of the best and
then he's like manly manly just oh
man chiseled up dude he does everything
sings his variety shows everything and
doesn't in any huge i think like sell
out huge venues yeah so he's
part japanese and park korea or he's one
i forgot exactly what it was but either
born korean and then
lived in japan because he's like
yeah
was he born japan moved to korea i
should know this because i remember but
i bet let's look it up but i bet he was
born he looks japanese i think he's born
japan moved to korea because who's
better at marketing and all that [ __ ]
than koreans
dude because he's the best of both
worlds oh yeah you're right poor in
japan
fourth generation japanese of korean
descent
acquired japanese nationality in two on
one but he considers himself both he
always has two flags on
japan he couldn't look more japanese
though yeah he looks more japanese for
sure
but uh yeah
dime piece of all nine pieces
so that's pretty cool yeah oh that's
going to be at 172. he used to fight at
185. i think he did both maybe but tough
fight for aoki yeah
but
okay it's all of them legs are screwed
yeah
for sure and there's another rematch
interesting and osp boy
osp1 the last one yeah
um okay
old school
and
fun fight yeah i'm not like chomping at
the bit to see it
no not really but it's cool yeah i'll
take it um scott coker said that dylan
dennis is
interested in fighting again you know
dylan dennis has been off for a while
he's been in the news he had that like
that that knee injury but then you know
at the bar and stuff getting wrapped up
by that big bouncer
you want the best for dylan dennis i
know a lot of you guys hate him i get it
i look at him from a different
perspective um
i hope he gets back to fighting man yeah
because him outside fighting he doesn't
have that it's trouble
exactly he is a good person i promise
you
he seems like a really good person i'm
telling you he's a good person man he's
just
again he subscribes to that social media
world so
his perspective is super skewed right
because
he's with connor and he talks [ __ ] like
connor and then you know he's not
fighting and then he's in the headlines
and he wants to fight jake paul on those
guys but you know he's in that toxic
world you know that
i i think you know when you sign up for
that toxic lifestyle and you know you're
getting views and stuff off it it has to
take its toll on you of course it's
gotta be tough to maintain and
especially when you're not competing and
then you're just left with that toxic
world i think that's why we're seeing a
lot of
craziness with dillon danisman
hopefully he gets back to 100 health and
starts competing because that'll take
your mind off of it and then
you know there's no better way to shut
the haters up than with success that's
the way you shut these losers up and
dylan dance can do that but when you're
not fighting it would it's hard to talk
[ __ ] man if that's your job
be like being a comic and not touring
and talking [ __ ]
you're not performing like what yeah so
he hopefully gets better man and gets
back out there yeah
well let's hope
alrighty uh this remember the iranian
hulk we finally see real video of him
and he's going to fight this guy martin
ford i'm sure you've seen him on
instagram he's just this gigantic buff
dude with all the tattoos yeah tattoos
so they're gonna fight in april i
believe april 2nd
and i think it's in dubai and look at
how it actually looks in real life oh
he's tiny so this is remember those this
is his instagram where he looked like
crazy right
six nine and we didn't believe it either
definitely photoshop definitely
photoshop yeah but you can actually see
him here
this is one thing that they did during a
face-off
oh he's not that big at all
oh
wow
that guy is huge
that was also a terrible take though
terrible and then check this out this is
screw terrible this is terrible
oh oh my god
that guy is jacked martin ford's
gigantic he's like super super tall too
but just yeah
not like no
what do you fall like he's gonna be
destroyed he's just in sweats
[ __ ] man well at least we know for a
fact like it's all this is social media
in a nutshell yeah
iranian hulk here we go and then [ __ ]
look at him
he's just a guy
yeah i bet he can bench a lot though he
has a perfect physique he definitely
doesn't look like no he doesn't look
like physique
he doesn't look anything like that he's
just good he's a great physique for uh
benching
he looks
absolutely ridiculous how many followers
does he have a million
well
but i mean after this
everyone knows now
it's fake
i wonder why he's doing it because the
gig is up i know it's like you know you
don't look like that you're actually to
go through this and you can't fight
you can't fight at all dude he's like
that
just that takedown's like holy [ __ ] dude
you don't have no clue what you're doing
what else you got
um
rampage's son he's uh 2-0 now oh that's
one
really dope second amateur fight god
it's tough when you're dead [ __ ]
rampage that's him right there raja good
for him man
yeah and then uh big shoes to fill yeah
so he won by submission too which is
cool that's cool
[Music]
oh you got a darsh joke though
yeah
how high level is anaconda to land that
to get that
um
i i'd have to see what the other guy's
background to pull it off against a good
guy you got to be pretty creative yeah
nothing too crazy though
especially if that guy doesn't have a
background jiu jitsu he doesn't know
what the hell is going on but you know
definitely good the guy was ono so it's
just the beginning that's where he's at
yeah that's cool
[Music]
um
i don't want to end on this one but so
this is jon jones reacting to the
footage coming out so you know the
footage just came out last week
yeah and john was like oh i was hoping
this got like
here's
[Music]
so this is what he says here first
i was hoping that video got lost in the
file somewhere okay like kind of making
a joke out of it and it goes don't don't
worry someone said don't worry i don't
think many saw and he says oh thank
goodness
and then someone says how you feeling
today champ anybody goes i can deal with
embarrassment it's the loneliness that
gets me taking things one day at a time
yeah i know uh let's see this guy to
those who prayed on my downfall no way
my god the story is far from ever far
from over i'm wise enough to know that
we all go through seasons in life i've
had many great ones and several bad ones
i'm excited for the next one about to be
heavyweight champion of the world
capable of so many things and loved
yeah there i have a soft spot for jon
jones man it's just very very sad the
entire thing
yeah the self-sabotage is just
you know you hopefully gets back on
track and fights at heavyweight and
as far you know
i would assume
losing his family wakes him up to stop
acting like a complete jackass you would
hope man
you lose your family
what else what more do
he's had money forever he's had money
lives in great houses drives dope cars
has all the guns and where the hell he
wants to collect
that you realize very early on like that
stuff is not happiness man
it's all about family it's the only
thing it's about and you lose them
if this doesn't get him on track
nothing will there's nothing it's gonna
be even worse dude he has a loss let's
say he fights cyril gone or you know
stephen loses
and the and you know he didn't train
right or you know he's he's back to his
old ways of drinking and going out and
doing whatever the hell he's doing it's
gonna get really bad
really really bad it's gotten so bad
already man so yeah yeah you gotta hit
rock bottom you know i mean what is this
rock bottom that's like even dom herrera
says there's even wiggle room at rock
bottom so it's uh i would assume losing
your family that's probably as far as me
goes that's rock bottom yeah for him i
don't know
i would hope that's his rock bottom
i don't know
but i hate to see it i hate to see it
man
and he's like yeah the lonely loneliness
is the worst part i [ __ ] bet
when you come home those kids aren't
there
your wife's not there your rider died
dude you've made so many shitty
decisions
they're not there anymore yeah yeah man
if this doesn't wake you the hell up
to get your [ __ ] together
nothing will it will only get worse
and i'm rooting for him i really am i
have a soft spot for jon jones
yeah
all right don't really want to end on
that one but let's see okay i thought
this was just pretty cool
this is uh
this is kabe's channel but what either
way kb was talking about magachev and
i'll just play for you
about too much media
like coach javier
if you don't want
just lose it's already gonna come yep
everything very simple relax relax this
is your job
over here this is your job
like like like coach say if you don't
want to make a lot of interior just lose
nobody gonna come
it's so true though it's very simple
yeah khabib's right but and that's the
other thing and i know that's
i don't want to say the knock because
there's no nakamaki but everyone says is
like him in the main events and the the
lights and the interviews he doesn't
like that stuff he tends to tense up so
we haven't seen his full capabilities
yet but i think once he embraces that
and i get it man it's a it's a beast
but you know
everybody wants to be a champ till you
have to do champ [ __ ] if you talk to any
champions some thrive in it i know other
champions very close where like it was
the worst man when i was champ i hated
it i had to do all these interviews do
all the [ __ ] all the time it was all
predicated on me i hate doing it i just
want to fight
don't become champ man just look like
frank mayer said heavy lies the crown
dude you wanna be champ you gotta do
champ [ __ ] you do stuff other fighters
don't have to do you're not gonna get as
much rest you're gonna be doing all
these interviews because we're banking
on you now
so you know
you won't be champ easy what you asked
for but i think machete figured out yeah
that's about it that's it yeah that was
fun man thank you guys for watching
thanks for listening again cowbest fight
campaign is this mother trucking
saturday josh barnett matt matrion
myself for ufc 272
kobe compton jorge mazvidal that's going
down at 7 p.m pacific only on the thick
boy channel we have a food truck
dropping wednesday with michael chandler
if you haven't seen the flashback fight
night with matt metron that's available
right now on youtube as well uh
housekeeping notes i'm back on the road
now that this cove is going away baby
your boy is back still doing shows
around la but um
my next time i'm on tour is let's see
shop and friends let's do our six
sellout we sold out every freaking show
i got some great people with me the next
shop and friends at the hollywood improv
march 9th one show only again on a
wednesday night 8 p.m shopping friends
hollywood improv let's sell that bad
trucker out um then nashville tennessee
one of my favorite rooms in all of the
country zany's in nashville
i'll have the squad with me in nashville
uh the thick boys are coming to town
that is march 10th through the 12th at
zaney's in nashville
um and then chicago is march 24th
through the 26th arizona is april 14th
through the 16th but nashville you're up
next and that is march 10th through the
12th at zany's in nashville tickets at
thickboy.com
and also we just restocked the oops
grenade it's a collab with crystalia and
myself it's a collab with crystalline
thick boy
we sold out in eight minutes and then
they put pre-order so you can go get
them right now the hats the hoodies the
tees thickboy.com the oops grenade go
get you some all right uh that's it kids
nashville i'll see you march 10th
through the 12th
i will uh see you guys saturday at 7 p.m
only on thick boy for the kai bass fight
companion for ufc 272 again josh barnett
matt matrion and myself and that's it
man enjoy the fights have a great week
love you guys like subscribe thick boy
i'm out
you